September 14th 2017 a day that will
haunt Muhammad Yunus forever he says he
watched as Myanmar's security forces
burned his village to the ground
managing to capture this moment on his
mobile phone looking back as he ran they
came in the early morning and surrounded
the whole village they opened fire
randomly so we ran away then they burnt
our homes in front of our eyes we wanted
to find some of the people you see here
focusing on this man with a water bucket
to find out what happened to him after
asking around we were told where he
lives in this camp in southeastern
Bangladesh so he went to find him
Muhammad is now 20 years old he tells us
they secretly went back to their village
of Haledon after the military left to
salvage what they could I thought my
home is gone but I'll try to save the
other two houses it seemed we could have
saved they weren't totally burned so we
went back but he says the security
forces returned the next day and on
September the 16th they fled to
Bangladesh I'm always thinking about my
home all that happens keep coming back
to me who was killed who was shot I keep
seeing it in front of my eyes I have
lived in sadness for two years now I
miss my country a lot of the videos were
retrieved from mobile phones that had
been broken or damaged while people fled
across the river I was able to fix some
of the mobile phones about a third that
came to me but most of them were damaged
by salt water all of the videos that I
have seen showed that it was the
military committing these crimes another
video we found appears to show terrified
Ranga running from their burning village
gunshots can be heard
we're Hendra that gathered evidence on
their phones through photographs and
video footage their courageous people
they took great personal risk to gather
the evidence and some of this evidence
is is revelatory and exposes massacres
and violence that happen
in Rakhine State and should be used in
future prosecutions we asked if anyone
had approached them to hand over the
videos is some form of evidence we were
told no this camp has hundreds of
thousands of witness accounts and a
potentially crucial photographic and
video evidence of the crackdown against
the rahaga the International Criminal
Court is looking into opening a formal
investigation it's been two years and no
one has been brought to justice
Stephanie Decker al-jazeera in the
rahega refugee camps of Cox's Bazar